So Leute, lull. Ganz schön früh noch für Sonntag streben. Sonst sind wir immer erst um 10 oder 10.30 Uhr am Start.
Ups. Moin. Übelster Residenz-Lieber. Muss mir auch gleich schon mal irgendwie was zu trinken oder was zu essen holen, irgendwas.
Rebuilding Windows 98 Pentium 3. Was gucke ich mir immer gerne an. Irgendwie sind die Videos alle gleich, ne?
Der Dude bastelt immer an alten PCs rum. Aber irgendwie gucke ich mir die Videos übelst gerne an.
Black Ops 1 Still Playable. Oh ja, da ist was von uns angekommen.
Ich meine, das hatte mal das Game, hatte mal ein Main-Menü mit Charakter irgendwie, ne?
Das ist halt das beste Main-Menü von allen Kotzen.
Getting Nukes with Terrible Classes. Schon noch kein Sinn drin.
Ich glaube es nicht. Wir gehen ernsthaft nach YouTube-Empfehlungen, was wir kaufen.
YouTube-Empfehlungen in 2019.
Nicht nice. Lull. Robelull.
Galileo. Wozu gibt es diese Kapsel an Kabel?
Kabel nicht reißt. Äh, nicht reißt.
Entweder ist das zum, zum, ähm, dass es nicht brummt.
Dass es nicht reißt.
Oder ist das Kabel ein bisschen flexibel.
Ich glaube das ist eher so ein, so ein, so ein, wie nennt man das? Bei einem Audio-Kabel.
Dass es nicht brummt. Wie heißt denn das bei Audio-Kabel?
Dieses, ähm, ich weiß gerade nicht aus dem Kopf.
Der Bucher, das ging brummt. Ja, ja, ich weiß aber nicht wie es heißt.
Interferenzen, ja irgendwie sowas.
Ich glaube das hat, das hat einen speziellen Namen, das Ding.
The Story in 1987 IBM PC.
Äh, das ist sogar mir zu alt.
Das ist sogar mir zu alt. Das ist witzig, ne?
Ich glaube, dass man das am interessantersten findet, was man kennt, so ne, eigentlich müsste man das, was man nicht kennt interessanter finden, aber ich gucke mir lieber PC-Videos an, von, von Sachen, die ich selbst irgendwie mitgekriegt habe.
Den Kerl kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Also die Videos mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das so beliebt ist.
DS, Mario, Cross, DS, E-Tron, 20 Minuten.
Oh nein.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich gucke wirklich, ich gucke wirklich YouTube-Empfehlungen.
Rack.
Racking Servers Correctly.
A Day in Life of Datacenter.
Das haben wir letztens doch schon geguckt, das war doch ganz, ganz gut, oder?
Also wie man Server rackt, also nicht, sondern ins, ins Rack einbaut, äh, ist eigentlich ziemlich einfach.
Du baust Schienen ein, und dann setzt du den Server auf die Schienen drauf, so wie er passt.
Das Einzige, worauf man eigentlich achten muss, wenn man Server in Rack einbaut, ist, dass der Luftfluss richtig, also der, wie die, wie die Luft, ähm, durchge-, durchbläst, ähm, dass das richtig rum ist.
Das ist aber das Einzige, worauf man achten muss.
Ganz schön früh, ja, ja, ich weiß.
Äh, ich weiß nicht, was da dran schwierig ist, hier.
Gucken wir mal, wie man Server richtig, richtig rackt.
Das ist Fake News.
Die Skills sitzen nicht im Operating.
Zaubericht nicht.
Nur noch hübsche Krills, das gibt's in Kombination im Operating nicht.
124 Team Support, gibt's das nicht.
Need for a Speed, 13 cares later, oh ne, Need for a Speed war 3, die hat mir nicht gefallen...
senator
Das ist krass, ey...
Das ist übelst krass...
Der erste ist 1'16, ihr müsst euch das mal angucken.
Das ist übertrieben.
Das ist so krass, die Leute, ey.
das ist so so gestört wie die abgehen was mal auf geht ja nur eine minute 20
pass auf das ist so übertrieben
und warum hat er warum hat der komische dragon ball musik er guckt euch das mal
an die türen sind übelst krass raufer hast du das mal gespielt und so komisches
game gewesen wo ich den hype auch nicht so ganz nachvollziehen konnte aber ich
verstehe dass es schwierig ist guckt euch das mal an aber gut die sind halt leute die
spielen wahrscheinlich auch seit zwei jahren oder so seit das rausgekommen ist
die ganze zeit dieses game aber das ist schon heftig oder das ist schon heftig
haben die verstanden warum da ein Amboss rumsteht
ja
also die dragon ball screaming skills sind am start
ich meine da hat er drauf warum hat warum hat er eigentlich einen goldkessel kriegt
man das nachdem man das game einmal geschafft hat und warum steht da ein
einkaufswagen da steht ein einkaufswagen weil random random items einfach aus aus
dem editor platziert würde ich sagen das ist so heftig also die haben es die
haben es übelst drauf die leute gibt es eigentlich für neue spielruns
ja da hatten die nicht so eine anzeige wo man sieht was als letztes
im interessantes game dabei was kurz ist
Yeah bad criminals in 2 stunden 2 stunden
Das wollte ich schon immer mal spielen
Ich habe es mir vor vor 1 1 1halb Jahren oder mal auf
steam gekauft in der neuen laute
Das soll richtig gut sein, hab ich aber nie gespielt
Aber wie kann man da einen smash speed runen?
Wie kann man dann einen smash speed runen?
Warum kann man dann einen whack raten?
Okay, das macht auch keiner.
Es gibt nur drei Leute, die das gerannt haben.
Wie kann man das speedrunnen?
Ach, das ist nur eine Stage.
Das ist nur eine Stage.
Das ist nur eine Stage und dann halt...
Das ist doof.
Das ist richtig dämlich.
Run nicht umsonst, nicht nur einer.
Nicht nur drei Leute.
Seit Jahren.
Donkey Kong Country, 48 Minuten.
Viertel interessanten Games dabei.
Hä?
Warum kann man Mario Maker...
Warum kann man Mario Maker überhaupt speedrunnen?
Wie speedrunnt man denn bitte schön Mario Maker?
Da fehlt was.
Fake.
Ach so, das...
Jetzt check ich's.
Das ist kein Speedrun, nicht Mario Maker, der speedrunnt diesen Challenge, nee, wie heißt das, diesen Endless, wie hat er gesagt, Endless Mode?
Nee, diesen...
Das, wo man halt die Dinger in Folge spielt.
Weil die Level teilweise übertrieben sind, ne?
Das sind so viele...
Ich finde Mario Maker besteht irgendwie gefühlt aus...
80% sinnlos Bullshit Level.
Und manche sind richtig nice.
Aber was ist das für ein Level?
Ich meine, the fuck?
Was soll das sein?
Ich meine, das ging jetzt auch, das ist wenigstens nicht so ein sinnloses Level, wo du auf dem exakt richtigen Pixel irgendwie abspringen musst.
Aber trotzdem...
Warum hat er da unten Bäume als...
Als...
Bild drin?
Was ist das für ein Level?
The fuck?
Warum?
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt an.
Das wollte ich mir angucken.
Kann man Black Ops 1 2019 noch auf der Konsole spielen?
Also, ich meine, die Antwort ist klar.
Die Antwort ist natürlich, kann man das noch spielen.
Aber wo ich meine Bedenken hätte, ist, wie verhackt die Lobbys sind.
Moin.
Stimmt, man konnte ja in dem Raum rumlaufen.
Ja, stimmt, ich erinnere mich noch.
Das war schon nice.
Das war...
Das Game war wirklich nice.
Ja, das war wirklich cool.
Das war wirklich cool.
Dass du einfach deine Ingame-Währung setzt.
Ich meine, im Endeffekt war es auch egal, weil du mehr als genug Ingame-Währung hattest.
Because you already knew you were going against...
...and people that wanted to take your money so bad.
So, we waited about an extra five minutes.
I actually stopped the recording, but we got a game.
Let's go.
Fünf Minuten für den Game.
The money amount is so little, but it's just still amazing.
One in the chamber.
One in the chamber was so perfect in this game.
I hate how they tried to redo it in the other Call of Duties.
It just doesn't make the same feeling.
It doesn't make sense.
It was literally beautiful with this gun and the bullet thing right there.
The three lives on the side.
Ja, das habe ich auch gern.
Bam.
Weg.
Oh, guck mal.
Da treffen die.
Die Schüsse wenigstens.
Nicht so viel Modern Warfare.
I missed.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Der direkt.
Oh, was?
Na gut, das war nicht ganz drauf.
Yes, let's go.
Den Spielmodus brauch ich aber auch.
Let's go.
Da sieht man, wie die Schüsse lägen.
Oh, my God.
Guck mal, sogar die haben eine Ping-Anzeige.
Ich meine, das ist keine wirkliche Ping-Anzeige.
Die haben diese komischen...
Ping-Balken, ne?
Aber noch nicht mal diese komischen Ping-Balken haben sie in Modern Warfare hingekriegt.
Das ist so frustrierend, weil du oftmals nicht weißt, hast du jetzt gesagt, hat das Game gebackt oder ist die Verbindung einfach schlecht?
Warum?
Ich habe es gestern im Video gesagt.
Ich habe es gestern 50 Mal im Stream gesagt.
Warum macht man keine...
Warum macht man nicht wenigstens Ping-Balken?
Und warum schreibt man nicht einfach eine Kackzahl hin?
Ich meine, die müssen das doch eh messen.
Wie der Ping zum Server ist.
Warum schreibt man das nicht einfach hin?
Let's go.
Dude, it's so nerve-wracking, because it's like you want to...
Das hat übelst Bock gemacht, weil du hast halt...
Du hast so richtig den Einfluss gemerkt, den halt ein Treffer hatte.
Aber ich mochte den Spielmodus auch.
Shoot first, but you don't want to miss your shot.
DLC.
Ping-Anzeige.
Ganz wichtig.
Tango down.
Das mussten sie immer sagen damals.
Das haben sie in Code 4 gesagt.
MW2.
Black Ops 1.
The bullet doesn't register right away.
I think we got the lead here.
I think we got the dub.
Always check the corners and one in the chamber.
Hä?
Das war ein Hit.
Das war ein Hit eben.
Guck mal, passt mal auf.
Ja, und jetzt?
Passt mal auf.
Ey!
Also wenn das kein Hit eben war, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das erste Video, was du von mir gesehen hast, war Gameplay auf dieser Map.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Ich hab ja ein paar Wager Match Sachen hochgeladen.
Sticks and Stones hat mir am wenigsten gefallen.
Was gab's denn noch?
One in the Chamber.
Und Gun Game.
Gun Game war nice.
Aber One in the Chamber hat mich am besten gefallen.
Yes!
Let's go!
MLC legit.
Oh, they need some good music for the win, bro.
Eton too.
We copped the dub.
Not even by a freaking chance.
Was war das? Ein geschlossenes Spiel?
Ich meine, es war ein geschlossenes Spiel, aber...
Es schockiert mich wirklich, dass wir ein Spiel gefunden haben, das wir als erstes gefunden haben.
Okay, also wenn ihr ein Waffen-Spiel probiert, und schaut euch das an...
Diese Ebenen, Bro, das ist verrückt!
Die originelle Dschungel, keine Black Ops 4-1...
Ich glaube, ich erinnere mich nicht ganz darauf, wie die Black Ops 1 aussieht.
Die Maps sind kleiner, oder?
Guck mal, das sind...
Sechs Spieler, also sind zwei Spieler mehr als in Modern Warfare gerade.
Aber die Map...
Die Map ist viermal größer und viel besser gemacht.
Die Maps in diesem 2vs2-Modus sind einfach nur der übelste Fail.
Spass!
Lag!
Oh!
Relagged!
Dino-Schuss!
Oh, wie Relagged!
Wie krass er gelaggt hat!
Gib mir diesen verdammten Schock ab, wenn ich nur seine Hitschritte bekomme!
Ich werde legitimiert verbrannt, ich muss einen verrückten Comeback machen.
Ich weiß, ich werde.
Tlutlutlutlutlut!
Der M16 Schuss-Sound war auch so nice in Black Ops 1.
Generell, Black Ops 1 war meiner Meinung nach der 2vs2-Modus.
Das ist mein Lieblings-Scot.
Spray, Spray, Spray, Spray, Spray!
Tzu!
Da war jede Waffe unterschiedlich.
Bis auf die SMGs.
Die SMGs waren teilweise übelst beknackte in Black Ops 1.
Nicht alle.
Ja, AK-47s, oh nice.
Aber das war alles mehr oder weniger...
Das wartet man nicht.
Oh, wir haben Start.
Ähm.
SMGs, die waren teilweise
sehr gleich in Black Ops 1.
Aber ansonsten war jede Waffe einzeln.
Leute, wir müssen jetzt mal
gucken.
Guck mal, M16
Burst-Waffe komplett anders als der
Rest. Gut, die Enfield war ein bisschen
0815, allerdings hat sie sich auch
unterschieden, weil sie eben relativ genau war
und langsam geschossen hat.
M14, Singleschuss, du hast
ein Farmer, ist übelst schnell und ordentlich
Damage, Tafel ziemlich verzogen.
Dann hast du die Galil, die war relativ genau,
hat aber auch langsamer geschossen.
Das hat alles irgendwie so eine
AOG, die habe ich glaube ich so gut wie nie
gespielt in Black Ops 1.
War auch Singleschuss.
Gut, war relativ ähnlich zur
M14, aber man sieht schon, es gibt
allerdings nur 1, maximal 2 Waffen, die ähnlich
sind. AK-47, war auch
relativ genau, hat aber merkwürdigen Recoil
gehabt. Galil, Chally,
super nice.
Kommando war auch cool.
G11 war wieder was komplett
anderes mit eingebaut.
Bottom Scope, äh,
Submachine Guns, die waren ein bisschen
fail, ne?
Also hier zum Beispiel Scorpion,
Mech und die Uzi
und das Ding und die MPL und die Spekker,
die Paris,
die waren alle jetzt nicht so
großartig unterschiedlich. Was rausgestochen
hat bei den SMGs in Black Ops
war halt die AK-74U.
Das war es eigentlich.
Der Rest war ziemlich gleich.
Guck mal, 30 Damage.
30, 30, 30.
30, 30, 30, 30, 40,
30, 50.
Ach ne, die Scorpion war das kleine
Ding, was übelst Damage gemacht hat im
Nahkampf, aber über Range gesackt hat, ne?
Genau.
Stimmt, ich erinnere mich.
Die hat im Nachkampf 2 hitted,
die Scorpion, allerdings war die über Range,
war die halt, hat die Damage vorlauf
Doom gehabt.
Äh, Shotguns, da gab es ja nur
3 oder so, ne? Olympia war auch
Double, Double Shot Shotgun,
übelst nice. Ähm, One Shot,
auto shotgun also single shot auto shotgun und das war das war eine richtige auto shotgun ich
glaube die hat kaum einer gespielt lmg legit gut lmg haste kaum gespielt in black ops 1 die war
ganz cool hier war mehr oder weniger ein assaultreifel hatte kein damage falloff gehabt
drivers gab es auch nur fünf oder sowas das ding hat keiner gespielt das ding haben die noobs
gespielt das haben die die beiden haben die lmg legit 360 no scope scope quickscope leute
gespielt die zwei hauptsächlich die l96 ganzen scope also möchte gern face leute haben alle
l96 eins gespielt das war's das war's alle waffen reicht doch reicht doch dicke alle waffen und
dafür bis auf den bis auf bei den smgs einfach alles umsonst
unterschiedlich das mochte ich übrigens auch an battlefield 3 die pistolen laden die pistole
lädt seite mit den pistolen lädt nicht also immer irgendwie laggt mein rechner gerade was ist da los
ah ne jetzt ist ja obs wieder kaputt ah jetzt ist obs wieder ganz obs spackt immer rum wenn man admin
berechtigung braucht und warum warum spackt mein rechner rum gerade noch gar nix wo es
was rum zu spacken gibt obs mit
kaffee und kaffee und kaffee und kaffee und kaffee und kaffee und kaffee und kaffee und
ganzen sieben prozent cpu last last ist ja ist ja nix scripted 64 sandbox das
ist in windows ja das stimmt bei battlefield 4 hatte insgesamt extrem viele waffen aber ich
finde halt es braucht gar nicht so extrem viele waffen als battlefield 4 ist ja komplett eskaliert
was waffen und aufsätze angehen aber ich finde es viel schöner wenn du vier oder fünf waffen
in einer kategorie hast du halt auch raus stechen
sowieso sagt man wie bad company 1 zum beispiel aber jede waffe komplett unterschiedlich neue
code ist oder man kann man kann wenig man kann ehrlich gesagt wenig draus ableiten aus
diesem modus weil es ist halt ein modus den will keiner spielen bis auf marco aus das
gibt ja mal gucken die meisten leute wollen tdm killstreak bashen ich glaube man kann
wenig ableiten ja das ist natürlich auch eine variante du machst einfach nur eine waffe rein
die du mit aufsetzen zu einer kommt zu komplett anderen waffen machen kannst du das ist natürlich
auch ein ansatz guck mal weiter ich meine wird das game hochgeladen haben weil er gewonnen hat
aber es ist echt mal nice oder black ops 1 zu sehen auf der strebe einflüssig was das was das
ist gerade gesehen
muss man die bitrate ein bisschen runter machen video output aber auch 4.000 runter
jetzt sollte das sollte das viel viel besser laufen streamst du im schlafanzug ich würde
es nicht schlafanzug nennen aber ich habe mich nicht irgendwie großartig umgezogen
ich habe nur kurz hosen und unterhemd aber ich habe was an
moment das haben wir
gar nicht gesehen wir haben wo ich habe gar nicht gar nicht zuguckt
l690 autoschneider dann dieser komische rgb nicht rgb rpg
schreckt das war dieses auto ding dann das lohr lohr teil loop tube granatwerfer
flug musik die black ops 1 musiker
jetzt kommt
der hat er CAD richtig glück gehabt dass er im crossbow eine so laufen laufen hatte
um parliament alles ist holistic live haben sie ja im black ops 4 ist es ja auch wieder drüben
bloß dass es im black ops 4 haben sich gedacht wir haben keine ahnung was wir machen oder wir
haben kein bock irgendwas ordentlich zu machen deswegen übertreiben was jetzt vor der black ops
40 jahres hatte auch ein eyes allerdings sind duка
Ballistic Knife, was du nur
über Kisten
Pay-to-Win ziehen kannst.
Und es soll mega OP
sein in Black Ops 4.
Erst mal in Arme geschossen.
Oh, Nuketown.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen.
Nuketown.
Das ist TDM?
TDM Nuketown. Es gibt ja wohl kaum was
klassischeres für Black Ops 1
als das.
Wobei ich Nuketown immer
Kack-Map fand.
Die werden dasselbe doch im neuen
Cod machen, oder nicht?
100% pro.
Deswegen glaube ich auch,
das ist eigentlich ein Thema
für ein Video, ich glaube,
dass Modern Warfare
mal wieder
im Kern
ein ganz gutes Call of Duty wird.
Es wird allerdings trotzdem Kacke werden,
weil sie irgendwelche
sowas in Richtung
Black Market oder
irgendwas in der Richtung einbauen werden,
nachdem die Refuse raus sind.
Das euch.
Das Game wird, das wird im Kern
ganz gut werden, habe ich so im Gefühl.
Aber sie werden es selbst
verkacken.
Zockst du mit dem Freesie eigentlich noch BDO,
oder habt ihr keinen Kontakt mehr?
Weder noch. Wir haben Kontakt, aber wir spielen kein BDO.
Der Fabian spielt ab und zu
meinen Account. Ich habe da jetzt sonst was
für Gier wahrscheinlich auf meinem Account, aber
BDO ist ein Game, das hat mich nie so
gecatcht.
On Newtown, G11.
Oh, G11, jawoll.
Eigentlich war die Waffe gar nicht so gut,
aber trotzdem Bock gemacht, wegen dem eingebauten Scope.
Three Nades, give me a kill.
Now I'll camp up in the window.
Brr, brr, brr.
Das bräuchte auch mal ein Video.
Max macht Waffensounds.
Brr, brr.
I just got that kill like three minutes later.
Oh, das war grösser.
Alright, we got some good 4-Bar, it looks like.
P2P.
Aber angeblich ist es ja vorbei, weil
dedicated servers, ihr wisst es ja, ne?
Das war ein richtig guter Spot,
hinter der Kontertisa.
Uh, Granate hinter diesem Auto auf Newtown.
Macht eigentlich Kaboom, ist schon
Jahr her, wo ich was, äh.
Ich weiß nicht, was er gerade macht.
Ah, they just missed me.
Abfall im Streik, jawoll.
Erstmal die Leute voll reingerannt.
Das sind aber auch, das sind auch wieder übelsten Bot-Gegner, ja.
Falsche Richtung, jawoll.
Dillu, dillu, dillu.
Die Spawns auf Newtown, guckt euch, guckt euch diesen Stumpfchen mal an, ey.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Und jetzt erstmal eine Runde, Runde raushauen.
Ich hab ja eine Xbox, ähm, One.
Ich müsste mal meine Playcrops 1 CD suchen, äh, DVD suchen.
Wir müssten fast mal eine Runde Playcrops spielen wieder.
Oder ich spiel's gleich auf der 360.
Bestion spielt's gleich auf der 360.
Mit dem Xbox-Controller, oh, das wird was.
Äh.
Naja, ich kann's dir bei Fabian sagen.
Der Fabian hatte auf jeden, der hatte keinen Bock mehr auf YouTube.
Ich sag mal, mir ist das nicht so gut.
Mir ist das nicht so gut.
Mir auch ein bisschen.
Ich find, YouTube ist als Plattform mittlerweile so extrem für den Arsch, ähm, dass ich da
auch meine Motivationsprobleme hab, ja.
Chopper-Gunner und Hunde draußen.
Das war so übertrieben mit dem Game.
Wenn du Chopper-Gunner, also nicht Chopper-Gunner, wenn du, nee, wie heißt das Ding, den Attack-Helikopter
und Hunde und so, wenn du, wenn du zwei killst, die Gegner sind nicht aus dem Spawn gekommen.
Vor allem nicht, vor allem nicht bei, bei Nuketown.
Und auf Nuketown war Chopper-Gunner eh das Niceste.
Wenn die Gegner das nicht abgeschossen haben.
Wenn du raus, wenn du, wenn du den Chopper-Gunner spawnen konntest und sie einmal im Spawn drinnen hattest, konnten die, hatten die noch nicht mal Zeit, wenn du gut, gut die Gegner gespawnt, killt hast, hatten die noch nicht mal Zeit, irgendwie großartig ihren, ihren, ihren, ihren Raketenwerfer rauszuholen.
Aber das, was wir hier sehen, ist der Grund, warum Leute Call of Duty spielen.
Die wollen, die wollen die Loops bashen mit.
Killstreaks.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute, habt ihr Bock, TDM zu spielen in Call of Duty, wo es Killstreaks bis zu, bis zu 20 Kills oder so gibt und dann übelsten Tryhard-Gegner zu haben und die, also nicht nur die Tryhard-Gegner, die übelsten guten Tryhard-Gegner zu haben, wo ihr, wo ihr und sie nicht über drei Kills kommen, ist doch langweilig.
Du willst, in Call of Duty willst du Loops bashen.
Wie willst du sonst die hohen Killstreaks?
Entweder Reverse boostest du, dass du so schlecht eingerankt wirst, dass du wieder gegen Loops spielst, was irgendwie auch vollkommen hirnrissig ist irgendwo.
Ja, das war's, ja.
Du willst Loops bashen in Call of Duty.
Und Loops bashen heißt ja nicht, dass du nur gegen Loops spielen musst, sondern einfach, dass du wild mit Leuten zusammengewürfelt wirst und du hast halt ab und zu mal ein paar Lobbys, wo halt die übelsten Hackbobs-Loops drin sind.
Das ist doch, das ist doch so.
Und dafür willst du...
Wozu gibt es sonst 2020?
20er-Killstreaks, wenn du die nicht erreichen kannst.
Technical Nuke.
Gegen gute Leute erreicht niemand einen 20er-Killstreak.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, das ist die nächste Variante, du spielst im Team und hast halt Support am Start.
Könnt ihr euch noch in MW3 oder wo das war, auf dieser Map mit der satten Lidenschüssel, dran erinnern, wie du mit Claymores, wie du mit Claymores Spawnpunkte manipulieren konntest?
Da haben die Leute im Vierer- oder Fünfer-Team gespielt, haben die Spawnpunkte dicht gemacht und einer...
Dome, genau.
Und einer hat halt hinter, hinter dem, hinter dem Boller mit der LMG gestanden und den Spawn reingehalten und das ist alles instant verreckt und da hatten sie irgendwie ihre, ihre 35, 40 Kills, Killgames.
These guys are getting destroyed.
Look at the score.
Sweet, sweet, sweet, sweet.
28 and 0.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
29 and 0.
Sind die nicht am Anfang gestorben?
That was an amazing game.
It's gonna be hard to top that, but we're gonna play one more, probably use a different gun or something, maybe one or two more, I don't know, depending how long, uh, this video ends up being.
Was machst du denn hier?
Schon ewig nichts mehr, was ich hier mache, äh, aufwachen, wie es im Titel steht.
Ich hab gestern übrigens ein Video hochgeladen, oh, und...
Alright.
Oh, noch ein Summit.
Ich mag die Maps aus Black Ops 1 auch.
Es gab ein paar Crap Maps.
Was gab's denn für Kack-Maps in Black Ops 1?
Was war denn so meine Richtung?
Muss mal kurz gucken, ich kann mich da gar nicht...
Array, Array ging mir auf den Keks.
Array war nervig.
Nuketown, also Nuketown ist zwar die beliebteste Black Ops 1 Map, aber ich fand Nuketown eigentlich auch nervig.
Havana war gut.
WMD ging so.
Kowloon ging auch so, das war eine DLC Map.
Final Range war nice.
Ist das der Golf, ist das der Golfplatz?
Das ist der Golfplatz, oder?
Die war auch nicht so gut.
Das ist der Code 5 Remake als Golfplatz, ist glaube ich, Herr Sand gewesen.
Radiation, kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, an die Map, ehrlich gesagt.
Das war eine DLC Map, kann ich mich null dran erinnern.
Hanoi, das war diese Gefängnismap, die war auch nicht so mein Fall.
Ah ne, da unten ist es.
Array hat gesagt, Jungle war gut, Kowloon ging so.
Berlin Wall war auch great Hiding Spots.
Convoy kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Launch war cool.
Cracked war...
Das war die in der Mitte mit den Häusern, ne?
Die war auch...
Naja, geht so.
Crysis war das mit dem Strand.
Ja, die war auch ganz okay.
Nuketown war nicht mein Fall.
Radiation kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Discovery, Discovery war das?
Ach, das war die DLC Winter Map, die war auch okay.
Drive-In kann ich mich auch nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Sagt mir gar nichts mehr.
Final Range war cool.
Silo, Silo war auch eine DLC Map.
Die weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Stadion war auch, glaube ich, eine DLC Map, die war ganz gut.
Ähm, Stockpile kann ich mich auch nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Sagt mir null, die Map.
Sagt mir gar nichts mehr.
Summit war cool.
Grid war cool.
Das war auch eine Schnee Map.
Ja.
Ähm...
Tanker 18 war, glaube ich, auch eine DLC Map.
Ja, die ging aber auch.
Äh...
Villa war gut.
WMD war auch okay.
Zoo?
Ach, Zoo war...
Zoo ist das nicht die...
Nee.
Ist das nicht die Stealth Clown Map?
Aber Stealth Clown war doch Infinity Ward.
Nee.
Ist das nicht so?
Ist das nicht Zoo?
Was ist das für eine Stealth Clown?
Was ist das für eine Stealth Clown Map?
Ist das nicht Zoo?
Ist das nicht zoo?
War das nicht zoo?
Hä, hä.
Der Typ, der war eh geil, ähh.
Ähm...
Hotel weiß ich nicht.
Havanna war gut.
Strong War auch...
Naja.
War das Gefängnis.
Das ging, glaube ich, auch ag80 gut?
Hazard weiß ich nicht mehr.
Also im überwiegenden Teil fanden ich die Maps eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber 50% fand ich richtig gut.
40%.
So geht es so.
Und 10%, kacke!
kacke das eigentlich ganz gute ausbeute für mich beim apps ja das war nice da
kannst du hier kannst du am anfang rüber rüber tomahawk und hast manchmal die
übelsten kills gemacht die famas hatte ganz komischen hipspray gehabt die hat
die hat von der hüfte hat die famas irgendwie so geschossen die hat nicht
irgendwie so geschossen überall die famas hat irgendwie hüftspray so gehabt
die hat nicht auf Prozessor gespielt s TEDMAM
die das ist ein ding unlimited herz na gut das war ja am anfang gesagt habe
ich glaube das ist der grund warum so nicht mehr spielbar ist weil ihm
alles voller hexo ist also vergessen wir dass die black ops 1 wohl
hast du das mitbekommen vom community manager wenn ja was sagst du dieser david
wanderer was hat er denn gemacht was hat er denn getrieben x-shooter
so will ich das aber auch machen wenn ich gegen cheaters am start bin
p2p als haus kannst du alles machen ja solange du zugriff auf die xbox hast
das ist ja das schwierige beim cheaten auf der konsole ist
wo ist irgendwie zugriff auf die sachen auf der konsole kriegen was meistens
nicht so einfach ist aber bei 360 dies alt
so gut farmers tiger streifen sind das tiger streifen das ist gar keine farbe
was ist da auch
auch auch
da habe ich
so
mutig ist gar nicht so gut start
wohnhofer blackbird das ist ein bisschen nass sie gehen wir fällen da
der
20 wieder was die auch gewesen ist die auch weil diese farmers farmers die
einfach nur anders aussah
oh mein gott das ist so oft
so oft wird aber es ist nass die
absurde das ist ein
Beste Waffe war immer noch AK-74U Rapid Fire, konnte man in Black Ops 1 zwei Attachments
an die Waffe machen?
Oder war das ein anderes Game?
Ne, das war MW3 mit zwei Attachments, in Black Ops 1 ging das noch nicht, in Black Ops 1
war AK-74U Rapid Fire, oder ging, Rapid Fire Griff, Rapid Fire Extended Mag, ging das, ich
kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern richtig, kann man zwei Attachments an die
Waffe machen?
Zumindest war AK-74U mit Rapid Fire der Shit, war so geil.
Mit dem Perk, wieder, wieder Cobra, Max das heißt nicht Cobra, das heißt Cobra.
Ja.
Ich hatte nur die Neune damals, ey.
Ah hier, AK-74U, beste Waffe.
Das war, das war so nice, die Waffe in dem Game.
Jetzt sind sie, jetzt sind sie im Arsch, die Gegners.
Ah, das ist so nice, dazu zu, ich würde das gerne wieder spielen, mach, aber nicht mit
den ganzen Hackern.
Ich hab einfach, da war einer in der Lobby.
Oh my gosh, they can't kill me.
Da habe ich jetzt gar keinen Bock drauf.
Da ist wieder der Instant Rage-Quick angesagt.
We're destroying them.
They're all sitting in their spawns just trying to kill my dogs.
Oh, except that guy, he's just camping.
The AUG is so good in this game.
It's probably one of my top favorite guns in this game.
Like I said, I love the Ironsight, and I love the way the guns sound in this game.
The M16 wasn't bad in this game, but compared to other games, alright.
Die M16 war nicht schlecht in diesem Spiel, aber im Vergleich zu anderen Spielen war die M16 besser als die WL.
GG, 38 und 5 hätten wahrscheinlich viel besser geklappt.
Ich wünschte, dass die Killstreaks in diesem Spiel verabschiedet wurden.
Ansonsten kann man nicht einfach Black Ops 1 im Shop kaufen.
Hat irgendjemand schon mal die Backwards Compatibility auf der Xbox One verwendet?
Muss dann die Original DVD im Laufwerk liegen für?
Oder reicht es, wenn man das Game auf seinem Account gespielt hat?
Also, nachher spielen wir noch eine Runde Modern Warfare Alpha.
Und dann muss ich noch ein bisschen auf die Xbox gehen.
Dann muss ich mal gucken.
Dann suche ich echt mal meine Black Ops DVD und dann spielen wir eine Runde Black Ops.
Stopp.
Ich glaube, ich kaufe das auf der One.
Ich habe meine Xbox One seit 3 oder 4 Jahren nicht mehr angehabt.
Brauchst du die CD, außer du hast die digitale Version?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Nope.
Jetzt.
Getting Nukes with Terrible Class.
Das ist wieder der gleiche Typ.
Der gleiche Typ.
Was wollen wir uns als nächstes angucken?
Hier nochmal eine Runde MW2?
Oder...
Die PC-Building-Geschichte.
Oh ne, 39 Minuten.
Das ist zu lang.
39 Minuten ist mir zu lang, das Video.
Mach mal besser jetzt an wegen dem Update.
Ne, ich kann jetzt kein Update sagen.
Da lag der Stream.
Das nachher.
Komm, wir gucken jetzt nochmal eine Runde COD.
MW2.
Ha!
Was ist das Ding?
RPK?
Ne, Dings...
M60 mit Schalldämpfer?
Oder was soll das sein?
Oder M240 mit Schalldämpfer.
Schreckt.
Are you serious?
Hahaha.
Lol.
Das war schon nice da.
Das war schon nice.
Yo, what is going on guys.
Fortunate here.
And today we are doing Nukes with terrible Classes.
Part 4, I wanna say.
Part 3 or 4.
In this video I'm doing classes I designed.
And if this video gets 5000 likes, I'll do classes in the comments down below.
Also, very quick announcement.
EGIT? Ach das ist Nukes with Terrible Classes.
Was ist das? P90 mit Thermal Sight? EGIT? EGIT? Wer hat denn sowas gespielt?
P90 mit Thermal Visier. Alter!
Oh, hier, könnt ihr euch noch, könnt ihr euch noch, wisst ihr noch, Leute, Favela, Favela, der, der, das Bart, wie sie sich, das war eines der ersten, eines der ersten so Call of Duty, wie nennen wir es denn mal, Call of Duty Social Justice Warrior Rage Geschichten, das Bart, das Call of Duty Bart, falls sich da noch einer dran erinnern kann.
Da hing mal ursprünglich, wahrscheinlich hier an der Wand.
Da hing ein Bild, was war denn das? Das war ein Bild, da stand irgendwas, irgendwas auf Arabisch drauf und da haben die sich übertrieben, also da wurden sie sich übertrieben drüber aufgeregt, weil, weil das Bild auf Arabisch hing in einem Klo und ein Klo, das wäre ja schon quasi gleich wieder Allah und Islam Beleidigung und sowas.
Und da haben sie sich übel drüber aufgeregt.
Und dann ist dann irgendwann, ist dann Infinity Ward hingegangen und hat einfach gesagt, okay, wir entfernen jetzt die ganze Map.
Und irgendwann kam die Map dann wieder und das Bild war weg.
Boah, haben sie sich da drüber aufgeregt, ey.
Meiner Meinung nach vollkommen übertrieben.
Ich meine, es ist, es ist eine Map in einem Game.
Es ist ein virtuelles Klo.
Auf einer, in Brasilien.
Ja.
90 Thermal Visier.
Das ist so, das tut schon weh anzugucken.
Payflow, ja boah, beste.
Das waren auch, das war eine nice Killstreak Kombi.
Harrier, Payflow, Chopper Gunner oder sowas.
Wobei, meistens hat man ja Harrier, äh, Chopper Gunner Nuke genommen.
Oder, oder, oder Harrier AC-130 Nuke.
Die ganze Flughafengeschichte war vorher, ja, aber das war noch was anderes, die Flughafenmission.
Die Flughafenmission, da haben sich eigentlich, das haben sie gezielt gefördert, dass die Leute sich drüber aufgeregt haben und, und das im Gespräch geblieben ist.
So dieses, so dieses, dieser Rage aus dem Nichts, über, über Nichts, ist das erste Mal, wo ich das mitgekriegt habe, mit dem Klo gewesen in Modern Warfare 2.
Nice, Harry.
That was like a commando launch and I don't even have commando on.
Oh, das Messern in MW2, ja.
Alright, the Payflow's gone.
Woops.
And my knife misses too.
My knife went straight through him.
Woo.
Oh my gosh.
Fakt.
Rage quit.
Like, why is he camping in a corner?
I'll take both of them, that works.
Du hast es halt damals gemacht, wenn du Nuke erspielen wolltest, bist du in ein Game rein, lief's gut, bist du drin geblieben.
Wurdest du gekillt, bist du raus, hast du ein neues Game gesucht.
Geh schneller.
LP90 mit, mit Thermal tut echt weh.
Get out.
In MW2 ist man auch extrem schnell gestorben, ne.
If you guys do enjoy these videos though, seriously, I need you guys to drop a like right now.
Ja.
And let me know down in the comments.
Können wir machen, ja.
Fortunate.
Get the nukes, also wenn's gefällt, ne.
Wir wollen uns ja nicht zu sehr mit Fremden fehlen.
Wir wollen uns ja nicht mit Fremden fehlen.
Ah, guck mal, der Edge-Lord ist da.
Der 690 auch.
Unless this guy gets a Chopper-Gunner next, that'd be terrible.
You know it's messed up, I just realized I had a Scrammler in this class.
Alright, let's go.
I gotta catch that first guy.
It's Chopper-Gunner.
Ich brauche einen guten Chopper Gunner hier.
Jetzt schießt er mich runter.
Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott.
Ich weiß, dass ich am Anfang Pablo benutzt habe, aber...
Ich brauche einen guten Chopper Gunner, weil ich sehr gestresst war.
Okay, ich nenne das hier ein.
Und wir werden mit der nächsten Waffe ankommen.
Kommt auf, spielt mal aktuell Reinhardt.
Kannst vergessen, ist für den Arsch.
Oh, hat nicht gemessert. Legit zählt nicht.
Nächstes Game.
Wer nicht messert,
hat die Nuke nicht.
Nicht legit.
Die wird nicht anerkannt von mir.
Das ist wirklich wichtig jetzt, wenn man das guckt.
Was spielt er jetzt?
MG4
Schalldämpfer
Red Dot Javelin.
Das ist ja auch eine beknackte Klasse.
Danger Close, Steady Aim,
Bling Bro.
Ach ja, genau, da kannst du zwei Attachments dran machen.
Wobei, es geht.
Es könnte schlimmer sein.
Können wir als Community nicht mal alle MW2 zocken?
Das könnten wir tun.
Aber ich glaube, meine MW2 DVD ist komplett kaputt.
Die hat glaube ich den Umzug damals nicht überlebt.
Lecker aufs 1.
Was ist denn hier gerade los?
Gibt so viele Follows.
Danke für die ganzen Follows.
Wo kommt ihr eigentlich her gerade?
Kommt ihr von YouTube oder kommt ihr über Twitch?
Was haben wir denn hier am Start?
Sag mal, der Serhit Rand hat gesubbt.
Habe ich das übersehen?
Habe ich übersehen, dass du gesubbt hast?
Samus Climber!
It's Batman!
Keep a Hands!
YouTube!
Ja, dachte ich mir.
Also, anteilmäßig kriege ich Sonntagsmorgens
immer relativ viele
Follows, aber nicht so viele.
Sonntagsmorgens ist irgendwie immer beliebt
in dieser Kategorie, irgendwelchen sinnlosen
Zeug zusammengucken.
Scheint auf Twitch beliebt zu sein.
Du kriegst aber jetzt
noch mal das Thema Nice,
wofür den Serhit Rand muss jetzt drin sein.
Nice, nice, nice, nice! Perfekt.
Ähm,
ich wollte irgendwas gerade nachgucken.
Was wollte ich denn gerade nachgucken?
Subscriber, legit!
Dankeschön, huge!
Samus Climber!
Stufe 1, ein richtiger
Sub! Kein Prime-Sub,
ein richtiger Sub!
Dankeschön, ähm,
legit, underscore!
Nice!
Ist der Chat cute oder
ist der Chat noch?
Worti, worti, Twitch über empfohlene
Kanäle. Echt? Wird empfohlen auf
Twitch?
Ist jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile WUP-S freigeschaltet?
Immer noch nicht, oder?
Die arbeiten sonntags nicht
und samstags nicht bei Twitch. Kann ich aber auch
verstehen. Würde ich auch nicht machen.
Samus Climber!
Bei der Gelegenheit. Vielleicht soll ich das Ganze noch mal erwähnen.
Falls ihr Amazon Prime
habt.
Und absolut
IIQ subscriben wollt,
hier, dass quasi
euer eigener, euer, euer, euer Hirn
größer wird, dann könnt ihr mit
Amazon Prime, Twitch Prime verbinden
und einen Streamer eurer Wahl
subscriben. Und euch kostet das nicht.
Kostet nix.
Ja, ich kann keine Sätze
gerade richtig sagen.
Richtig aussprechen.
Aber danke für die ganzen Follows und die Subs.
Was ist denn heute los hier? Wen haben wir denn hier?
Wen haben wir denn hier bei den Follows am Start? Der VB!
Äh, nee, VFB!
1, 9, 9, 3,
1, 1, 1, 2,
Zemax,
BartIsMoreThanLove,
Crystalsky,
Luki,
80, Meme Machine
905, Friedrich, Underscore, Underscore, Underscore,
Underscore, Tizzy,
ähm, ich spare mir mal die
Zahlen, die ihr alle hinten dran habt.
AGB,
Seven, Basic,
Plekki,
ColLazy,
TijuanaGaming, Swift,
Wer seh ich nicht mehr?
Die Anzeige ist, äh,
bei Steamlabs ist ein bisschen Fail.
Aber die Klasse ist wirklich, äh,
ich könnte schlimmer sein, aber sie suckt.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wir spielen mit MW2 alles so schnell.
Erstmal noch eine Javelin auf die Map ballern.
Zack.
Double kill, now he's gonna get Harriers.
Great.
Okay.
Der ist grad nicht wirklich einer,
da ist grad nicht wirklich einer am Javelin
gestorben, oder?
Ihr müsst mich übrigens mal ein bisschen mehr nerven, falls ich
irgendwelche Subs übersehe.
Da bin ich froh, dass es besser geworden ist.
Es hätte seit Jahrzehnten
gefühlt schon in Call of Duty vorbei sein können.
Ja, bisschen übertrieben jetzt. Wobei, also,
übertrieben ist das gar nicht, wenn man sich das überlegt,
wie lange es das jetzt schon gibt.
Ähm, hätten sie einfach nicht nur
gesagt, damals gefühlt bei jedem Call of Duty
dedicated Server,
sondern das gemacht, ja, dann wäre das alles
kein Problem gewesen.
Hast du The Boys of Prime gesehen? Ja, übelst nice.
Letztens erst geguckt. Hat mir gut gefallen.
Ich hab mich schon gewundert,
warum das alles so gut zusammenpasst,
bis ich gesehen hab, dass das nach irgendeiner Comicvorlage
ist, wobei sie wohl auch ziemlich
abgewichen sind davon.
Aber, ähm, in der Regel,
alle Serien, die irgendwie Hand und Fuß
haben, basieren meistens auf irgendwelchen
Büchern, Comics oder irgendwas.
Wenn nicht,
dann sind die oftmals wir.
Übrigens, ich will jetzt mal was zum Thema Serien sagen,
ja. Ich hab keinen blassen
Schimmer, warum The Walking Dead
so einen Hype hat.
Oder hatte. Ist ja nicht mehr so.
Was die Leute an dieser Serie
fanden. Ich kann's
nicht nachvollziehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Was da, was die, was das ist.
Das ist ein bisschen so,
ähm, wo ich auch
nicht verstanden hab, warum alle auf Game of Thrones
so abgegangen sind. Ich hab Staffel eins, zwei,
drei, äh,
ich glaub die vierte, hab ich so zur Hälfte geguckt,
ähm,
und danach wurde das einfach
übelst räudig,
äh, sinnloses
Rumgeschwätze, die halbe
Staffel, so getan, als hätte es irgendwie
Bedeutung. Und dann
ist eine Sache passiert, was die komplette
die kompletten letzten drei
Folgen obsolet gemacht hat.
Der Buchhalter!
Stufe eins, potnice. High IQ.
IQ vom ganzen Chat wieder gestiegen.
Ähm, dankeschön, Prime.
Ne, nicht mal Prime, richtiger, richtig echter.
Ich drück einfach mal random Encryption Emotes.
Vor allem das Windows hat's jetzt voll was damit
gebracht, ey.
Ja, aber, aber Game of Thrones ab Staffel vier
war übelster
Crap.
Und ab da ist der Hype erst richtig
angezogen.
Zumal man auch gemerkt hat,
finde ich, dass ab Staffel
vier ihnen die Buchvorlage ausgegangen ist.
Oh, der ist mal schön geneift.
Controller Aim in
2019.
Aber, ich darf da nichts sagen, ne.
Ihr habt meinen Controller Aim vorgestern gesehen.
Du hast Staffel sieben und acht nicht gesehen. Ja, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab fünf, sechs, sieben, acht nicht geguckt.
Ich hab nur mitgekriegt, dass acht
übertrieben gehatet wurde.
Wahrscheinlich zu Recht.
Da wieder Chopper Gunner.
Aber so ist es halt. Harrier, Chopper Gunner,
Nuke.
Harrier, Chopper Gunner, Nuke.
Musste sein.
Perfekt.
Scheiße, was.
Scheiße, Fail.
MW Spawns, Alter. MW Warfare Spawns.
Das ist so unfaire Rage-Kacke.
Harrier, Chopper, Nuke ist kein Killskrieg,
sondern eine Lebenseinstellung.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man da kein Damage
kriegt.
Hey, Stimoweb.
Sieار planeta Forbidden Nook.
Okay, MW Spawns.
Hey, hello there.
Tweety Töyoung.
Anyways,
Die MW Spawn ist richtig f Huaise.
Die 173 competed,
und die 142 Chris Pir Chan and H750
sind sekarang
Die MW2-Maps waren alle relativ klein, es gab ein paar größere, diese komische mit den weißen Steinen, die da rumgestanden haben und gab es sonst noch für eine größere, diese Schneemap, die war, was war das, derailed? Die war auch noch relativ groß für Modern Warfare, also für Cod-Verhältnisse, aber was man an dieser Map richtig gut sieht, das ist Scrapyard, ist das, oder?
Ist das Scrapyard? Chat, enttäuscht mich nicht.
Okay, es ist Scrapyard. Ich finde, Scrapyard ist ein super Beispiel dafür, wie man eine Map machen kann für diesen 2vs2-Modus.
Diese Map ist fast genau so, wie alle 2vs2-Maps. Du hast eine gespiegelte Karte, einen Weg links, einen Weg rechts, einen horizontalen Spawn oben, einen horizontalen Spawn unten.
Trotzdem, trotzdem haben sie es geschafft, ja, das kommt ja, die 2vs2-Maps sind noch kleiner, aber trotzdem haben sie es geschafft, dass man auf dieser Map halbwegs ordentlich TDM spielen kann.
So, und ich finde, sowas wäre eine optimale Map für diesen 2vs2-Modus. Die 2vs2-Maps aktuell sind einfach viel zu uninspiriert und viel zu klein, als dass man da ordentlich gescheit drauf spielen kann.
Und, was man auch sieht, dass die Modern-Warfare-Maps, einfach, die 2vs2-Maps, einfach nur total uninspiriert kacke aussehen.
Guckt euch Scrapyard an, das ist, das Ding hat quasi den Schrottplatz schon im Namen, ja, und die Map sieht gut aus.
Es ist ein Schrottplatz, es hat coole Feuereffekte für die Zeit dazwischen gehabt, also man sieht, man kann auch eine Schrottplatz-Map machen, sodass sie irgendwie ansprechend oder was besitzt.
Und dann vergleicht das mal mit, ähm, mit den 2vs2-Maps. Die 2vs2-Maps, unabhängig davon, wie sie sich spielen, sehen einfach kacke aus.
Die sehen richtig kacke aus. So richtig, so richtig wie, was ein Level-Designer macht, der zum ersten Mal seinen Level-Editor aufmacht.
Jemand, ich weiß nicht, Leute, hat jemand von euch mal ein bisschen Maps gebastelt?
Ja, bei der Editor dabei, ne?
Ähm, hab ich ein bisschen Maps gebaut.
Und eine der ersten Maps, die jeder anfängt zu bauen, ist eine Schrottplatz-Map.
Jeder. Jeder baut eine Schrottplatz-Map.
Mit, mit sinnlosen, sinnlosen Kisten, Wänden und, und, und Holzaufstellern und sowas im Weg.
Und die Maps, die der übelste Half-Life-1-Worldcraft-Loop gebaut hat, und, und Container und so, die sehen so aus, wie diese, wie diese...
Diese Schrottplatz-Ball-Map in 2 vs. 2.
Genauso wie der übelste Kack-Level-Design-Noob.
Und das nächste, was man dann baut, ist, ah ok, man baut mal ein bisschen Natur-Map.
Und das nächste, was man dann baut, ist als Level-Designer-Noob, ist so eine Map wie Pine 2 vs. 2.
Das ist das nächste, was man dann baut.
Dann baut man eine Map, eine Mini-Map mit zwei gegenüberliegenden Spawns und baut ein paar Bäume rein.
Das ist das nächste, was man baut.
Und dann stellt man fest, die Map spielt sich kacke, also was macht man?
Man stellt einen Container rein und zwei Autos.
Und fertig ist Pine.
So miese, also von der Optik und vom Design-Standpunkt her Maps, habe ich selten gesehen wie in diesem 2 vs. 2 Modus.
Also die sind richtig schlecht, die 2 vs. 2 Maps.
Das wirkt wirklich, als hätten sie den Praktikant dran gesetzt.
Der Praktikant hätte gelernt, wie man den Level-Editor bedient.
Hätte irgendwie in seinen drei Wochen, wo er da war, fünf Maps erstellt.
Und dann haben sie sich gedacht, oh ne, lass mal einen Spielmodus in diese zwei Maps bauen.
Ich finde vom Ansatz her, ist dieser 2 vs. 2 Spielmodus in Modern Warfare gar keine so doofe Idee.
Vor allem, weil es die ganze Random-Geschichte ist.
Aus Perks und sowas rausnimmt, weil jeder immer quasi Mirror-Out spielt.
Aber die Maps sind einfach übertrieben räudig dämliche Kack-Maps.
Jawoll, und der andere braucht noch einen Kill.
Oh mein Gott, los geht's!
Los geht's!
Das war unsinnig, er hat auch 30 Kills.
Du musst messern, du musst messern, messern, messern, messern, messern.
Ja, er hat es.
Die ist legit, die Nuke, die zählt.
Die Nuke zählt.
Noch eine, ey, der Typ will es wissen.
Also ich muss sagen, die Videos von dem gefallen mir echt gut hier.
Und er hat nur 208 Subs.
Eigentlich voll wenig.
Für die Gameplays.
Gameplays sind huge nice.
Jeez, Louise.
16 ACOG, übelste Sacker-Klatze, ey.
Everyone's gonna noob-tube now.
Anyone else?
I just want the scav-pack somehow.
Completely out of there.
An A-Tank ist die beste.
Harrier's nice and early, that's good.
Not getting me any kills, though, that's not good.
They're all camping in there.
Alright, we'll see.
Campen in der Höhle, ja.
Thank you.
Shot down, it dodged it.
Nice.
Someone's shooting it, look.
Brrt.
Alright, we got an AC-130, good, good, good.
See if I can get some kills with this.
Genau, erstmal ins Handfeld legen.
He didn't pass?
Jawoll.
Die 100, den 120-Millimeter-Ding.
Den spawnen, jawoll, so geht das.
Zack, bam.
Did I get a hit?
No, I didn't get a headshot.
Okay, okay.
Jawoll, komm, bam.
Didn't that get a kill?
Boah.
That's two kills, sorry, cool.
Das hat sich auch übelst geil angefühlt in dem Game.
Wenn du...
Wenn du einen 120-Millimeter-Schutz abgeschossen hast
und das ging auch nicht.
Das ging auch nicht.
Das ging schon raus, weil es abgelaufen ist
und das flog noch
und hat dann 1, 2, 3, 4 Leute gekillt.
Das war so nice.
Der kriegt jetzt wahrscheinlich keine Nuke.
Der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich gekillt von der Seite.
Eins vor Nuke.
Vorbei, genubtubt.
Boah, boah.
Fuck.
Ich sag doch, ich sag doch, er stirbt eins von Nuke.
Ich sag's doch.
Ich spiel doch einfach nur Runde Black Ops 1.
Ich such nachher mal meine DVD.
Dann kann ich endlich mal wieder meine Xbox anwerfen.
Are you really kidding me, dude?
He just rushes out like that?
Oh my gosh, man.
Why does this keep happening to me?
COD ist einfach das Game, worum geraged wird.
Es gibt kein anderes Game, wo man so extrem rumrageden kann wie COD.
Overwatch geht auch, aber nicht so sehr wie COD.
NW-2 ist, glaube ich, die DVD.
Die DVD ist kaputt.
Oh my gosh.
How many bullets did I put in him?
Viele.
Wahrscheinlich haben sie nicht registriert.
I got cold blood on this class, that's good.
Here we go.
Ne, zerkratzt, nicht zerbrochen.
Zerkratzt.
Zerkratzt, aber nicht einfach nur zerkratzt, sondern es ist unten einfach, es ist von der, nicht unten, es ist von der Reflektionsschicht, es sind Teile abgebrochen.
Die DVD kannst du nicht.
Kannst du vergessen.
Warum nicht, dass diese DVD irgendwie funktioniert noch.
Äh, Xbox 360 oder Xbox One?
Ja, wenn schon, würde ich es auf der, auf der Xbox One spielen.
Allerdings würde ich es am liebsten mit dem 360-Controller spielen, weil ich mit dem 360-Controller am besten kann.
Hm.
Auf Steam.
Ich glaube, man kann Black Ops auf dem PC nicht spielen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich verhackt sein ohne Ende.
Außerdem sehe ich es nicht ein, dafür irgendwie nochmal 30 Euro auszugeben oder so.
Das ist viel zu teuer.
Go for it.
Harriers, send it back.
Harriers, let's go, come back for a second.
Go, Harriers, get some kills.
Bam.
Nice, a double kill.
Oh, I'd love to see that.
Helikopter sending by.
Chopper gunner.
Oh, baby, run back.
Please don't catch him.
Sehe ich spielbar, aber die Server sind leer.
Alright, let's do this.
Come on.
My Harrier is getting some...
Black Ops 1 hat übrigens einen sehr guten Job gemacht, damals, als es aktuell war, für diese 1-2 Jahre, cheatfrei zu sein.
Ich habe selten, ich habe kein Call of Duty auf der Konsole erlebt, was so lange keine Hacks auf der Konsole hatte, wie Black Ops 1.
And.
MW2 war ja im Endeffekt schon fast seit Release.
How many kills?
And no...
Yo, look at his lobby, oh my gosh.
Did it, did it, did it, did it, did it, did it, did it.
If I don't get this, I'm gonna be...
Oh my gosh, come on.
Juk, go, go, go.
They're spawning right next to me.
Boah, das ist Failspawn.
Jawohl.
Yes, let's go.
I know this one with a lot of killstreaks.
Easy, Juk, easy life.
Easy.
Easy, er ist einfach ein Killer.
Ich werde diese schrecklichen Chokes benutzen und versuchen, solche Schrecken zu bekommen.
Wenn ich all die Chokes gezeigt hätte, bin ich nicht verrückt, dann wäre das Video wahrscheinlich über eine Stunde lang.
Ultra-Low-Latency-Modus, der den Frame-Buffer quasi ausschaltet.
Wie will man denn überhaupt was rendern ohne Frame-Buffer?
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Ohne Frame-Buffer kannst du nichts rendern.
Das klingt nach Nvidia-Marketing-Zeug, ey.
Ah ja, ja, Chat.
Zeit, mich mit einer Retrospektive auf ein PC-Game von meiner Jugend zu fühlen.
Das ist Unreal, entwickelt durch Epic-Megagames und Kollaboration.
Ruge-Game damals.
Wahrscheinlich kennen, ich hab ja gesehen, hier die meisten irgendwie paar 90 geboren oder so,
die könnten Unreal noch kennen, aber wahrscheinlich kennen das die meisten Leute.
Unreal, Unreal war das Crysis meiner, meiner Zeit, ja.
Also meiner, meiner Generation.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht, ich hab ja Crysis, ich hab Far Cry, Far Cry, Crysis mitgemacht.
Aber Unreal war quasi das erste Crysis in der Form, dass es, ähm,
grafisch neue Maßstäbe gesetzt hat, so gut wie auf keinem Rechner gelaufen ist, als es rausgekommen ist,
und erst ein bisschen später richtig gut ausgesehen hat.
Kommt da von die Engine, die heute alle Spiele haben? Ja, ja, ja.
Interactive on May 22nd, 1998.
Man, 1998 was how long ago?
98, 98, das war ein Jahr vor Half-Life, nee, Moment.
Nee, nee, Schwachsinn, ein Jahr nach Half-Life. Half-Life kam 1997, ne?
Ja.
Was, ihr seht nix?
Wie, ihr seht nix? Wollt ihr nix sehen?
Da sieht man was.
Half-Life war 1999, wirklich?
Ach, ich dachte 97, nee, 98.
Ja, manchmal bringen wir die Jahre schon ein bisschen durcheinander.
16 MB lang, ne?
Ja.
Unreal, yes, this is an actual PC-Game-Screenshot.
Hehe.
And, dude, that really was...
Ja, sah damals, das, also, damals waren die Leute übertrieben beeindruckt,
nicht, also nicht durch die Gegner-Models, ne, weil die Gegner-Models sehen tatsächlich ein bisschen, ja, aus,
sondern dass man Outdoor-Areale spielen konnte, die, die gut ausgesehen haben und Wassereffekte hatten und so.
Heute hat man schon 16 MB, 16 GB, ja.
Also, die Models in Unreal waren schon, waren noch nie der Wahnsinn, die war schon immer ziemlich eckig.
Sogar für damalige Verhältnisse waren die, waren die eckig oder nicht viel besser als der andere Kram.
Was bei Unreal richtig gut war, waren halt die, die, äh, die, äh, die Level, die Architektur, also die Jahrstellung von, von Aus nach Realen und sowas.
Für Februar 1997, als Next-Gen-Magazin dieses Buch veröffentlichte,
behaupten wir, dass bei der Zeit dieses World-Reveal-Magazin-Artikels
id Software's Quake nur acht Monate alt war.
Also, von in-game-Charaktern, die so aussehen,
zu diesem, war ein notierbares Verbesserung.
Weiterhin, als Fan von Titeln,
das stimmt, aber wenn man sich das mal vergleicht, mit, sagen wir mal, mit Half-Life und so,
Half-Life sah für seine Zeit auch schon nicht überragend gut aus.
Ähm, also die Models waren nicht das, was Unreal beeindruckend gemacht hat damals.
Wohlgemerkt, Quake war acht Monate raus, und das wurde neu angekündigt.
Das hat noch ein bisschen gedauert, bis es rausgekommen ist.
Das waren Zeiten, wo man so ne...
Alter, ich hab... muss mal was trinken, ja.
Wie gesagt, gerade erst aufgestanden.
Wobei, ich bin schon wieder ne Stunde on, ne?
Ähm, das waren Zeiten, wenn man da ne Voodoo-Grafikkarte hat, war man voll, voll huge.
Hast du Mädchen 2 gespielt? Nein.
Das war, war mir zu Asia Crying, äh, Pay2Win-mäßig.
Ich kann nicht weiß, ob's Pay2Win war.
3D-Shooter ever made, only a few years after developing those 2D-DOS-Games,
that was a bit surreal, or unreal, if you will.
Huge joke.
Heck, when Unreal finally released,
Jazz Jackrabbit 2 had only come out two weeks prior.
So seeing both a silky smooth 2D-Platformer
and a silky smooth 3D-accelerated FPS arriving under the same banner
within the same month was just like,
pff, what? How?
And even with Unreal arriving just five months after Quake 2's release...
Dem Kerl gefällt seine Special Edition echt gut hier, oder?
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Special Edition war.
Damals hatten ja alle Games noch ne Box, die irgendwie auch nach was aussah.
...release, it still felt like a generational leap in PC-Gaming-Graphics,
and the box tried to make that abundant.
Das stimmt.
Was aber auch, was man auch dazu sagen muss,
ähm, das Grafikkarten damals, wenn du da irgendwie für 400 Mark,
hättest du theoretisch schon fast ne SLI Voodoo 2 kaufen,
ne, nicht ganz, nicht ganz, für 600, ne SLI Voodoo 2 kaufen können,
dafür kriegst du heute ne Mittelklasse, obere Mittelklasse Grafikkarte.
...clear.
Other first-person shooters often covered their package and logos and artwork
providing some abstract representation of the game,
but...
...unrealized.
...unreal went balls out from the start.
Plastering embossed renders of his 3D-Models right on the cover
and including a square cutout showing one of four screenshots.
And it was all topped off with quotes like
the best-looking game of all time,
the future of gaming,
and rest in peace, Quake.
Das ist ja heute immer noch so, ne?
Wir haben's ja bei der Gamescom-Eröffnung gesehen.
Die Spiele, was ich total grotesk irgendwie finde, ist,
auf der Gamescom-Eröffnung haben sie
Spiele gezeigt,
die
noch nicht released sind, logischerweise,
die jetzt aber schon Preise für das beste Game und sowas gewonnen haben.
Wo ich mir auch nur gedacht hab, wie...
Geht das bitte schön?
Best-looking game ever.
Das war das best-looking game ever!
...to.
The hyperbole continued around back as well,
with copious screenshots and descriptions
cramming in every bit of self-congratulating marketing copy they could.
Das ist damals genauso wie heute.
...in hindsight,
but at the time they truly had...
...earned the right to brag about their tech,
so hey, why not?
...and if you needed any more confirmation
about how long ago 1998 actually was,
check out the list of products it's optimized for.
Not a single one of those APIs, instruction sets,
or multiplayer networks exist anymore.
...at least...
Ja, Leute, ähm,
das war Voodoo-Gedöns,
was damals ja voll angesagt war.
Damals war mit Nvidia und, und, ähm,
da gab's Riva 128 und sowas war voll übelst gesackt.
Ähm...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
M-Player ist für mich nen, ist für mich nen VLC-Alternative
und nix, weiß nicht, was das ist.
Won, das kennt, das sagt mir noch was.
Ich glaub, das erste Half-Life,
das erste Half-Life-Multiplayer lief auch da drüber.
Glaub ich.
Power VR Extreme.
Oder VR von Virtual Reality steht eher nicht.
Gut.
Intel-Gedöns-Marketing-Kram ist natürlich heute immer noch drauf.
...at least not in the form they did back then.
Sad.
Inside the box, you get a bit of an unusual...
...usual cardboard insert.
One that's built to hold the jewel case all snug,
so the cover screenshot is visible on the front of the box.
And mine is cover variant number two of four.
And inside you get the game on a single CD-ROM,
as well as a booklet that contains not the manual,
but even more screenshots.
Die fanden sich halt geil, die fanden sich halt geil damals.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die so viele Models gezeigt haben.
Die müssten, die müssen Umgebung zeigen von den Leveln.
...a late night away from irresponsibly buying on eBay.
And yep, there was also a Macintosh version of the game
ported by Westlake Interactive,
which was set to release in June.
Und es gab Spiele-Hotlines, ja, es gab Spiele-Hotlines.
Ich hab damals bei der Nintendo-Club-Hotline öfters angerufen,
zu Super Nintendo N64-Zeiten,
und wollte dann irgendwie die Sachen wissen, die ich nicht kapiert hab.
Ich hab übelst was im Hals, was ist denn los?
...but didn't actually show up until a year later.
For that matter, there was also going to be a Playstation
and a Nintendo 64 version of Unreal,
with none other than DMA Design,
a.k.a. Rockstar North, working on porting the latter
to the 64DD system.
But both were canceled because of reasons.
Back to the box, though, where you also get this little catalog
for GT Interactive's offerings for Spring of 1998,
including existing releases like Unreal
and upcoming releases like Duke Nukem Forever.
This long-awaited sequel is coming in Winter 98, huh?
This video.
Once you've got Unreal installed in your graphics card,
Könnt ihr euch noch an diese hässlichen Installer erinnern?
Die sahen damals fast alle so aus.
...properly configured, it's time to dive into...
Das sah so... das sah so schlecht aus.
...the most anticipated PC-Gaming...
...this is not an uncommon sight
when it comes to the launch version of Unreal.
Bugs and crashes are a fact of life.
...going so far as to include this slip of paper in the box,
calling for their hardcore gaming audience
to please forgive them in advance.
Because making games is hard
and Unreal is full of bugs, so...
Das ist ja geil! Das ist ja geil!
Heute würde das anders laufen.
Heute würde man erst mal abstreiten, dass es Fehler gibt.
Man würde erst mal abstreiten, dass es Fehler gibt.
Und das Nächste, was man da... was man da nachgemacht würde, ist,
erst mal den fettesten Day-One-Patch aller Zeiten raushauen.
Und wenn das nix hilft, würde man wieder nix sagen.
Daniel Null, zwei Monate aktuell.
Pock, nice, Subscriber!
Nice.
Guck, dass ich nix übersehen hab. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Please be sure to download the latest updates as soon as possible.
Yeah, I can think of a few companies who should still be including messages like this,
but anyway, thankfully there are patches for just in advance.
Die haben gerade gesagt, man soll... man soll...
Man kann sich subscriben, dass man Infos kriegt über die neuesten Patches.
Because making gameplay there are patches for just about every configuration of PC imaginable.
So, once it's working, you're greeted with the legendary Unreal Castle Flyby Demo.
Oh, Leute, überlegt euch mal.
Das war... war's 97 oder so?
Nee, 98? 97?
Man kam's noch mal raus.
98. Guckt euch das mal an.
Also, es sieht pixelig aus.
Es sieht auch von den Effekten nicht gut aus.
Aber überlegt euch mal.
Das ist ein Game von 98.
Ja, genau, RTX on übrigens auf der Brücke, ne?
Überlegt euch mal.
Es sieht sogar für heutige Maßstäbe anschaubar aus, ja?
Und das kannst du nicht über viele Games von damals sagen.
Euronics, EU, dankeschön, Twitch Prime, POG.
Nice, Subscriber.
Zwei Monate schon, huge.
High IQ Subscription.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich meine, es sieht nicht gut aus für heutige Maßstäbe.
Man kann es sich noch anschauen.
Ah, Dude, yes.
Every time I start this game up and I hear that mod music playing, composed by Alexander Brandon and Mikhail Vandenbos,
in combination with those glossy 3D surfaces flying by, brings me right back to the first time I saw this running.
It was just me in my living room with my Compaq that ran Windows 98 SE, sitting there in awe at what was happening on my screen.
I kept thinking.
My computer can do this?
Granted, I mean, I had upgraded it with a 16-megabyte-billion-threadlock.
Game Overlink, das ist ein interessantes Comment.
Da fällt mir spontan was zu ein.
Er schreibt nämlich, denke, wenn die sich beim Programmieren mehr Mühe geben würden, bräuchte man nicht so viel Speicher.
Ich glaube, es liegt hauptsächlich daran, man muss einen Mittelweg finden.
Wenn man halt was Fertiges nimmt, wie Unity, was halt sehr viel Komfort bietet, dann muss man natürlich ein bisschen einboosten machen, was so das letzte Mal war.
Das letzte Quäntchen Performance und das letzte Quäntchen Hardware-Optimierung angeht.
Dafür hat man eine Entwicklungsumgebung, wo man halt relativ easy Content erstellen kann.
Und ich glaube, wenn man abwägt zwischen wie performant was ist und wie viel Content man mit einem überschaubaren Team produzieren kann, sind wir heute theoretisch besser dran als früher.
Früher war es unglaublich schwierig, Games zu entwickeln.
Sowas wie Unreal war, das war technische Meisterleistung für damals.
Oder das erste Rollercoaster Tycoon, das war komplett in Assembler programmiert.
Das macht gerade keiner mehr, der noch halbwegs bei Verstand ist.
Dafür war es halt auch schwierig, viel Content einzubauen.
Unreal war kein langes Game.
Oder auch kein Game mit super viel Inhalt in dem Sinn.
Dass es heute natürlich ein bisschen abstrus wird.
Dass wir heute Games haben, die viel Content haben.
Content in Form von, sagen wir mal, unterschiedlichen Sachen, die drin sind.
Oder halt polished Sachen, die drin sind.
Und die trotzdem dann nur 5 Stunden lang sind.
Das ist halt irgendwie ein bisschen beknackt.
Aber wir hätten heute die Möglichkeit, und das machen ja auch einige, guckt euch Witcher 3 an zum Beispiel.
Oder GTA oder irgendwas, da gibt es noch mehr Beispiele.
Man kann heute Spiele vom Ausmaß basteln, eben durch die ganzen Hilfen, die man hat.
Sagen wir mal mit Unity.
Mit einem Team, was überschaubar ist.
Witcher ist übrigens ein scheiß Beispiel dafür, weil es benutzt nichts davon.
Und GTA ist auch ein dummes Beispiel, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber ich glaube, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Das war halt bei Unreal nicht so.
In order to make it happen, so I knew it technically could, but knowing and seeing were two different things.
And seeing this in the late 90s running on your computer was practically a religious epiphany to a PC gaming geek.
But impressive visuals can only carry a game so far.
And Unreal is much more than a tech demo, so let's get to it, starting with the main menu.
And dang, I had completely forgotten this is what the UI looked like originally, with no mouse cursor and a chunky green typeface.
Anyway, let's begin with the single player campaign and its offerings of four difficulty levels.
You can choose the character models to choose from.
What you pick out here is pretty inconsequential to...
Da, da, da. Man konnte damals sogar schon Mädels spielen.
Weil sie sich letztens wieder darüber aufgeregt haben, dass Frauen nicht richtig repräsentiert werden in Spielen.
Das war damals, 98 war...
...since you play a silent protagonist in a first-person perspective.
But I appreciate the gesture regardless.
And now it's time to wake up.
Damals gab's schon Mädchen, das ist generell Frauen im Internet.
Frauen im Internet, das ist absolute Fake News.
Gibt's nicht. Kann nicht sein.
Alles fake,
auch auf Twitter.
Alles deep faked.
Und was damals auch, was
richtig Unreal typisch war,
und ich finde, was man lange Zeit auch noch
bei Unreal-Spielen gesehen hat, mittlerweile haben sie es besser
im Griff, ist, dass
die Proportionen
irgendwie nicht stimmen.
Also von Spielermodel
Höhe zu Räumen.
Das sah ganz lange
bis, teilweise noch bei Unreal 3
Games, ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt,
sah das irgendwie
falsch aus.
Das sah alles so gestaucht aus in Unreal-Spielen
früher.
Teilweise bis Unreal 3 Games, doch mittlerweile
haben sie es im Griff.
Das ist halt...
...ein ganz anderes Spiel, das mal wieder
eingestiegen ist.
Also, eigentlich ist das
so, dass so das Spiel
zu einer Ausgabe kommt,
des bis jetzt
vollen
Unreiche des
Rikers.
Du findest sofort eine Tablet-Match
auf dem Herzen, und gehst von der
krümmelnden Schiff darunter
zu den Krümmel-Motschlägen,
die du nur durch das Schreien
von unschuldigen Crew-Mitglieden
indierender verleuchtete unerwarteter
Horror.
Und wow! Das hat damals einen
großen Erfolg gemacht.
Ich hatte nie an FPS gespielt, mit diesem ngoßem Umfang, wie man es bis jetzt fragt.
Und das ist, das ist noch nicht mal, als du das gesehen hast am Anfang, hast du dir halt gedacht, ja okay, es ist so ein bisschen, ein bisschen Doom-Style irgendwie, Station, Innenräume, aber dann bist du ins Freie gekommen.
Das war, das war richtig. Das hier, das hier sieht jetzt, das sieht gut aus für die Zeit, keine Frage, aber das hat dich noch nicht so umgehauen, ja, außer halt von der Atmosphäre drumherum, aber das hat dich noch nicht so umgehauen.
Aber wenn du rausgekommen bist, war das wirklich hübsch.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal, guckt euch mal den RTX, den RTX-enabelten, ja, den RTX-enabelten Boden an, ja, 98, RTX On.
Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, war das ja gefakt, die haben einfach das Level gespiegelt.
Ich habe damals ein bisschen mit dem Unreal-Level-Editor rumgespielt, das war einfach gespiegelt.
Die hatten einfach das gleiche Level nochmal, nochmal 180 Grad gedreht.
Auf den Roten drunter gepappt.
Wo ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern kann, ehrlich gesagt, ist,
ob es in der Zeit, in der ich das Spiel gesehen habe,
ob Unreal 1 schon diese Alternativ-Feuer-Modi hatte.
Ich glaube schon, das ist ja das, wo Unreal und auch Unreal Tournament so ein bisschen berühmt mitgeworden ist,
dass die Waffen unterschiedliche Feuer-Modi hatten.
Ich glaube, das hatten die auch schon.
Dass du quasi in ein Projektil schießen konntest und das dann mit Primärfeuer abschießen konntest,
dann ist es explodiert und sowas.
Du hast was von Emotes gesagt.
Werden am Anfang nächster Woche neue Emotes freigeschaltet?
Ja, ich hoffe jede Minute drauf, dass neue Emotes freigeschaltet werden.
Aber ich glaube, die arbeiten Samstag, Sonntag nicht, was vollkommen verständlich ist.
Ja, viele Gegner hatte Unreal wirklich nicht zu bieten.
Das ist nice.
Ey, da hab ich mir in die Hose geschissen bei dieser Sequenz.
Stehst du in dem Gang drin, da ist hinten die Tür zu, es geht nicht weiter.
Lass mal aufhören.
Du bist nice.
Und du kannst nicht zurück.
Du kannst nicht zurück und dann geht das Licht aus.
Du hast übelst in die Hose gemacht, ey.
Ja, das ist noch ein anderes Ding.
Unreal machte einen schweren Einsatz von Dunkelheit durch die Kampagne,
ohne Zweifel, um seine dynamischen Lichter-Kapazitäten zu zeigen.
Also musst du oft die Flaschen nutzen, um dich zu lichten,
zumindest bis du die verschiedenen Lichter später findest.
Aber alle diese Lichter-Sourcen sind temporär,
mit den Flaschen, die nach einem kurzen Zeitraum explodieren,
und Lichter, die aus der Batterie fliegen.
Es sah aus wie ein Predator, die Dinger sehen auch aus wie Predators.
Das ist auch sehr stark davon inspiriert.
Die haben auch diese komischen Klauen in der Hand.
Ja, richtig, sehe ich genauso.
Das war damals übelst...
Naja gut, die Einstellung jetzt vielleicht nicht so...
Aber das hat einen damals extrem gehypt.
Man hatte weitläufige Ausnachjahre, das gab's damals nicht.
Das war damals, ey, du hast fast schon Gänsehaut gekriegt,
wenn du das gesehen hast.
Guck mal, ich mein, der Wasserfall hat sogar Wellen geworfen.
Ein WTF, was ist das?
Das hat man...
Das haben die zehn Jahre später nicht gesehen.
Das hat man nicht gescheit hingekriegt.
Wobei, ja, es ist der Open-World-Vorläufer, könnte man so sagen.
Wobei, die Open-World in Unreal ist nicht wirklich open.
Die sieht nur open aus.
Das ist eigentlich fake open.
Das Gebäude war nicht nur massiv, sondern auch wunderschön,
mit seltenen Kreaturen, die herumfliegen,
ein Viertel in der Distanz,
seltene Rappen, die vorbeigehen, die geschossen werden,
und der Geräusch eines Wasserfalls in der Distanz,
während mehr dieser tollen Tracker-Musik spielt.
Nur zu sagen,
das Wort Unreal bringt solche Umgebungen in die Hand.
Sie sind schön zu sehen,
aber isolierend, um innerhalb zu existieren.
Sie besitzen nur genügend Detail und breiten, offenen Raum,
um dich zu enthüllen, um weiter zu erneuern,
ohne dich gleichzeitig zu überwinden.
Und diese Art von kleinerer Geometrie des Polygon-Gesetzes,
finde ich einfach verdammt schmerzhaft.
Ich meine, es ist wie...
Das hatten die damals gerne in Spielen,
so komische, so komische Platforming-Elemente,
wo du dann...
In Half-Life war das auch ganz schlimm,
wo du über Kisten runterspringen musstest und sowas.
Also, lineare Level im Open-World-Design,
na ja, eigentlich waren die...
Ja, ja, ja, genau, so ungefähr.
Also, eigentlich sahen die Level in Unreal Plus groß aus,
aber es war immer ganz klar von A nach B.
Wir sind auf ganz wenigen Ausnahmen.
Ja, Objective Marker gab's eh noch nicht.
Habt ihr gesehen? Fisch-KI.
Fisch-KI. Habt ihr das gesehen? Fisch-KI?
Fisch.
Fisch-KI.
Schwimm weg vor dir.
Und zwischendurch war Unreal übelst verwirrend,
wo du hin musstest.
Das hast du manchmal überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Also, die haben wirklich viel eingebaut,
was erst Jahre, wenn nicht sogar Jahrzehnte später,
populär wurde.
So ganze Physikkretzel-Geschichten und sowas.
Also, Unreal war, muss man echt sagen,
in fast allen Aspekten, was das Technische angeht,
seinerzeit meilenweit voraus.
Es gibt auch freundliche NPCs,
die sogenannten Nali,
die dir helfen werden,
wenn du genug Geduld hast,
um sie lebendig zu halten.
Sie öffnen alternativen Routen
oder Geheimdienste von Waffen und Power-Ups.
Natürlich wollen die weniger leidenschaftlichen Aliens
nicht, dass das passiert,
und werden eine B-Line machen,
um sie zu töten,
bevor sie dir helfen können.
Also ist es ein Muss,
schnell und präzise mit deinen Waffen zu sein.
Sprechend von Armamenten,
es gibt zehn Waffen im originalen Unreal,
viele von denen werden dir ziemlich bekannt sein,
wenn du die späteren Spiele in der Franchise gespielt hast.
Die erste Waffe, die du erhältst,
und die wichtigste von ihnen,
ist die Dispersion-Pistole.
Eine Low-Power-Energie-Waffe,
die sich über die Zeit wiederholt
und wahrscheinlich auch für das Schießen von Objekten
wie Kratzen und Pistolen verwendet wird.
Sie hat aber auch die unique Möglichkeit,
sich mehrere Male zu verbessern,
indem du durch das Spiel Boosters erhälst.
Dann gibt es die Auto-Mag,
eine Hitscan-Pistole,
die unglaublich effektiv ist,
aber auch rechtsträhnend ist.
Sie hat auch eine Sideways-Gangsta-Mode,
bei der du für irgendeinen Grund
viel schneller schießt,
um die Leistung zu verlieren.
Dann gibt es die Stinger,
eine Art Rapid-Fire-Chain-Gun.
Das Ding habe ich schon wieder komplett vergessen.
Sie schießt aber auch Pteridium-Schaden
in einer direkten Linie
oder einem langsam effektiven Sprechschuss.
Ach stimmt, das war die Shotgun.
Das war der Shotgun-Ersatz.
Ja, ich erinnere mich wieder.
Die GES-Bio-Waffe,
das Bio-Ding,
das gab es im Anvil-Tournament später auch,
ist etwas ungewöhnlich,
denn sie schießt Blöcke
aus toxischem Wachstum
in verschiedenen Größen.
Danach gibt es die ASMD-Schock-Waffe,
eine fantastisch nützliche Waffe,
die kraftvolle Energiebeamte
in einer direkten Linie
aus jeder Distanz schießen.
Ja, das ist das Ding,
wo man das Ding dann in Luft jagen kann.
Dann gibt es die secondary Fire,
die eine pulsierende Energieball schießt,
die dann mit der anderen Beam schießt,
um eine noch größere Explosion zu machen.
Ja, stimmt, das war es.
Dann gibt es die Mini-Gun,
die viel wie die Stinger funktioniert,
außer sie benutzt die gleiche Ammo
wie die Auto-Mag
und ihre secondary Mode
schießt an einer unterschiedlichen Stufe.
Danach gibt es die selten genannte
8-Ball-Launcher,
die eine 6-Ball-Launcher ist,
nicht 8.
Und Granaten.
Genau, das Ding konnte auch Granaten laden.
Ich fand, das waren voll kreative Waffen,
obwohl es eigentlich nur noch 15 Dinger waren.
Aber es war irgendwie was Neues.
Es war nicht so die übliche Geschichte aus
Raketenwerfer, Assault Rifle und Pistole und Shotgun.
Es war irgendwie was.
Was ichfetter in meiner Meinung ist,
ist Black Cannon.
Ja, das war ein Schlag.
Es war auch Shotgun und so und ...
Das war auch Schotgar und ...
Außer hier gibts gehaltene Schrapnel,
die überall springen
und die Töne von Fehlern zur Seite abschneiden
und auch einen Schsellraucher.
Die gab's zu Anakin später auch.
Das ist fantastisch,
wenn man viel Letzte-Whythmie verursacht,
wenn man genug hat.
Falls ihr es gehalten habt.
Danach gibt es den Razorjack,
der ist ziemlich mächtig,
aber es schützt oft mehr Probleme als es wichtig ist,
weil es da von gestapolisierten Schnecken springt,
die überall springen
und er kann jenmit den Händen des Jungen ausreißen,
its path including you and it also has a rather gangster secondary sideways
firing mode because you had to make that weapon cool somehow and then finally
there sniper rifle easily one of my favorites in this and every other unreal
title it's a powerful armor piercing hitscan weapon that disconnects heads
from torsos in spectacular fashion and is a pleasure to use
ich will nicht dass es lädt ich will nicht dass es lädt den gibt es übrigens noch
ich hab letztens irgendwo was gelesen dass das das das hier das das angry german kit oder so
wie es da die zig zig videos von gibt den gibt es wohl noch den den ich will
unreturnable den echten gangster
die aforementionede translator flares and lights
ja so geht's da flach skuba gear jump boots in visibility in a single use
force field but probably the most useful one is the amplifier which has nothing
to do with your high five set up and everything to do with making your
weapons more powerful when activated there's also the nali fruit seed one of
the more creative health items i've seen most of the time you're just
picking up kann ich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern
round but every so often you'll see a seed which can be activated by planting
ich glaube das habe ich nie verstanden dass das geht
kann ich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern
and waiting for it to grow seriously you'll find these out in the world to
already grown but when you plant one the longer you wait the more health you'll
get from the plant up to 30 health points it's weird and inconvenient but
that's neat and you will want all the seeds and health items you can get
because unreal does not always take it easy on you difficulties as you imagine
i enjoy how almost all of the power ups and weapons you find aren't yours alone
and will inevitably be used against you
and almost all of the game's twenty something enemies are quite skilled in
dodging and switching up their attacks so it can often be a serious challenge to get a
bead on them defending on what you have at your disposal and what exactly is
attacking there's a respectable variety in
them as well including skin roots crawl gas bags mercs slith flies mantas titans
and if you're not keen on jumping spidery facehugger like things well too bad
Oder 1KS.
Ja, das war die Gegner.
Ja, die Gegner fand ich auch langweilig.
Es wurde schon langweilig mit der Zeit.
Das stimmt.
Perfekt waren die Spiele damals wirklich vom besten Willen auch nicht.
Ja, das war richtig dumm.
Das war richtig dumm.
Glücklicherweise musstest du nicht zu lange warten, bis die Erweiterung von Unreals einzigartiger Erweiterung nach Napoli zurückkam.
Die Erweiterung war 1999.
Verfolgt von Unreal Gold.
Das war eine Runde Modern Warfare Alpha.
Wie lange läuft denn die eigentlich?
10 am PT.
Was ist denn das? 20 Uhr oder so, hm?
19 Uhr, da müssen wir noch spielen, Leute.
Taugt dir Modern Warfare bis jetzt?
Ich halte mich noch zurück mit Sachen zu dem Game, weil dieser Spielmodus ist nicht das, was das Game irgendwie, was die meisten spielen werden.
Also die Waffen fühlen sich gut an.
Der 2 vs 2 Spielmodus suckt.
Und, ähm, vor allem durch die Maps.
Also bis heute nicht.
Ja.
Heute 19 Uhr sind die Server offen, da müssen wir unbedingt noch ein paar Runden spielen.
Da geh ich, ich, Leute, ich geh jetzt auf, ich futter was.
Und nachher bin ich wieder am Start mit noch ein bisschen MW, mit ein bisschen MW2.
Äh, nicht MW2, mit ein bisschen Modern Warfare.
Ich nenn's mal MW4, weil man das einfach besser aussprechen kann.
Und...
Ich muss noch gucken, ob ich gleich keine Subs verpasst hab.
Nope, hab ich nicht.
Und dann spielen wir noch eine Runde, bis die, bis die Server closen.
Ja, danke für die Subs, für die Follows.
Und wir sehen uns später.
Bis denn.
Wie viele Subs hast du jetzt eigentlich?
Ich guck mal nach.
Äh, ich guck mal, ich sag's, ich kann's dir gleich sagen.
Ich habe aktuell...
Weil die Steamlabs-Anzeige ist, ist beknackt.
Laut, laut, äh, Streamlabs hab ich 196, was nicht stimmt.
Weil es nicht checkt, wenn, wenn Subs auslaufen.
Ähm...
Ich hab 140... 140.
Darf man fragen, was du beruflich gelernt hast?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf.
Na, erzähl ich zumindest, was ich grade mache.
Gelernt hab ich Fachinformatik und Systemintegration.
Ok Leute, ich geh jetzt auf.
Ich muss was frühstücken.
Und, ähm, damit ich nachher noch ein bisschen Modern Warfare spielen kann.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
See you.
Blblblblblblbl.